ان صور وصول الرئيس الصيني شجن بينج اذن
الى مقر عقد قمم الرياض مع الصين طبعا قبل
قليل كانت بدات القمه الخليجيه الخالصه في
دورتها الثالثه والاربعين الان ينضم
الرئيس الصيني شيجن همم الى القاده
الخليجيين لعقد القمه الخليجيه الصينيه
الاولى بين الطرفين
اذن هذه الصور وصول الرئيس الصيني سجن بنك
الذي همم
عقد قمه مع اهل السعوديه الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز بالامس في القمه السعوديه
الصينيه واليوم اذا هو يشارك مع القاده
الخليجيين في القمه
الخليجيه الصينيه اذا كما نتابع هو الرئيس
الصيني اذا ينضم الى القاده الخليجيين في
مقر
القمم في الرياض
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام هي ثلاث قمم مهمه جدا
طبعا مع حضور الرئيس الصيني شي جيم بينج
الاهم الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه والتي
اذا بدات بقمه سعوديه صينيه توجد بالامس
طبعا توقيع اتفاقيه شراكه استراتيجيه بين
السعوديه والصين اليوم عقدت قبل قليل
القمه خليجيه في دورتها الثالثه
والاربعين والان تعقد القمه الخليجيه
الصينيه لتليها بعد ذلك القمه العربيه
الصينيه كذلك بحضور الرئيس الصيني جيمنج
اذا الذي يحضر الان همم من المفروض اذن
بعد قليل هو دخل القاعه كما تبعنا معكم
على المباشر يحضر بعد قليل الى همم
فعاليات هذه القمه الخليجيه